gentlemen it's been a year how are you
doing
already wow yeah I was when I was
prepping for this interview I'm like oh
my God it's been literally a year
um which is crazy so I have a ton of
questions I want to start with just
obviously Keanu thank you for coming out
uh during the Comic-Con panel
um I just want to you know in case just
wanted to say thank you thanks man it
was fun
uh yes it definitely was
um so jumping into the why I get to talk
to you guys um for fans of the comic
what do you think would actually
surprise them to learn about the making
of the comic behind the scenes how much
Ron suffers
[Laughter]
I think they assume that how much you go
out of your way to make me suffer
these guys are
statistic slave drivers I thought we
were just torturing the character
it's like you know there's
just kidding it's it's a lot of work for
him and there's you know and I think
we're hopefully hopefully Ron finds it
interesting just the different styles
different genres the different
this the the kind of width of the
emotional bandwidth you know going from
violence to love to grief to mystery to
yearning
and then traveling through you know
history right to all of the costumes
animals the settings you know it's it's
a big show
no yeah believe it or not I sleep right
over there in my studio I have a head
right over there because sometimes I
have to get right up and get right to it
so I sleep right there
why are you sleeping
four hours well I think I think Ron's
trying to let everything subconsciously
enter the brain when he's sleeping in
the room that that's my takeaway okay
we'll allow it that's what I think you
know Keanu sits in front of a blank
background all the time because he's
absorbing things from the universe
you know all these ideas that's what I
try to do in my studio sorry go ahead no
I was just going to say I'm curious
because obviously now there's been many
issues out and fans like to talk about
I'm just curious how much are you guys
looking on social media reading what
people are saying and taking what the
feedback is from the fans to possibly
incorporate into the writing or whatever
you might be doing on the creative side
I don't know about you Ron Matt doesn't
read reviews I tend to read the the when
when they're I'll read like four on per
episode and I try to or issue I try to
read the really good ones and then we're
really bad ones
guess what
guess what I don't read them but guess I
get them read to me
I don't
it's even in a way it's like because
we're so
we're writing and creating as we go
along we really let each issue kind of
you know we try in the form of it to
like answer some things and then propose
new things and try to keep it propulsive
and definitely I've taken in like
um
you know notes of like okay so where
else can we go what might be interesting
what's interesting to us you know we can
only do what our taste is
but you know we can take into you know
um I'm trying to think of a specific
idea of
like what we've internalized and from
from feedback
yeah you know just to exp expand on that
for a second Steve is that
in the reviews a lot of the times
you have to decide well when you read
them
there's certain criticisms that you
might read that are only particular
criticisms to the person making the
critique it's not a critique of the art
or the writing it's a critique of like I
read one recently
um not long ago about the way I drew a
hand you know and so it's like
I you know you have to kind of pick and
choose the things that you think are
valid and the things that you think
aren't
um I'm always up for
any valid criticism that's constructive
if it's not constructive I don't really
want to have too much to do with it
because sometimes it can get very
acerbic
and I'd rather it not be because
you know if somebody wants us to take
what they're saying into consideration
then it should be a constructive
criticism you know so I don't venture
too much into that territory but here
and there you know when I do I take what
I think is good and what I don't think
is valid you know I leave that to the
side so I think the best thing you can
take from reviews to me is like seeing
what what we're doing is landing or not
or people are understanding what we're
doing you know or if there's a
disconnect between what our intent was
and then what people are getting out of
it you know like that that's good to me
because it's like oh well maybe we
weren't clear enough here or maybe that
didn't land quite right and we have to
be you know I mean there's there's
things in reviews that are helpful from
a creative standpoint you know but um
yeah as far as drawing hands hands are
hard to draw
foreign
I definitely want to know where are you
right now in the writing and drawing
process in terms of uh future you know
issues uh so issue 10's out and
um Ron is drawing Issue 11 and Matt and
I are writing issue 12 which uh boom has
been really cool and they're letting us
do a double issue
oh sorry no I was just gonna say I
finished 11 actually
uh well you've got some notes wrong
very few very few
I'll look so forward to those
uh I am issue 12 is something I actually
wanted to ask you guys about because
ultimately you've been working on this
now for a while and how much is the
finale if you will or is this the finale
I actually don't know um how much has it
sort of been exactly what you expected
and how has it changed along the way in
terms of you know where you ultimately
end up yeah so
um
yeah we're writing it you know
first of all we thought we had so much
uh boom set out like from the very
beginning it was a 12 issue limited
series
um so we knew that going in that we had
to tell this story in 12 issues
um and then as soon as they said yes
that
um we said yes to that we were like can
we have a double issue to start it and
they were like okay
and as we've been developing there's so
much story that we want to kind of
tell but also have the space to do the
emotions of what's going on
um so it's not just plot uh we were like
can we have a double issue at the end
and then they were like yeah and then we
were writing it and we're like can we
have two more we actually bought it
eight more pages
the two pages kills me they gave us two
extra pages
um and no I mean I think we had an
overview we you know
Matt talks about like there was always
like a kind of end so we knew where we
were starting and where we were ending
but how are we getting there and
what is the ending
um
uh or the end of the 12 issues you know
we're still kind of cooking up because
we always kind of take in the last issue
that we wrote and then what do we want
to feel and see and what would be cool
to do next
I actually because I'm going to run out
of time as you guys know collider we
cover movies and TV a lot
um and I'm very excited about the fact
that you guys are working on a movie and
an animated series on the property
um what can you I know you at Comic-Con
you announced a two season order for the
Animated Series can you talk about where
you are in the actual development of the
Animated Series in terms of when people
might see it and how much is the
Animated Series going to follow the
comic book and how much is it going to
be its own thing
right now we're talking to a Japanese
anime company and we had some
preliminary meetings and they're we're
waiting on them to come back and tell us
what version of berserker they want to
do
um you know for me uh it's not like here
are a couple of rules
the rules of the character can't change
um born 80 000 years ago cursed with
violence you know origin story but after
that you can do whatever you want so in
terms of the Japanese anime company
um we're talking to ig and and seeing
what they would find interesting what
they what they propose so we're LED you
know creatively what do they want to do
sure I get um the other day Madsen who's
writing your screenplay for the feature
posted a screenshot of the script and
the end and fans got very excited have
you guys read the script he did I didn't
know he did that yeah yeah the other day
he did what yeah he just it said go it
said cut to Black the end I didn't know
what it was for though I knew what it
was yeah I haven't read it no because
then he posted another photo of like the
title page or whatever
um basically he's saying that he
finished his draft of the script so I
was just curious yeah he did he did I
got it yesterday or two days ago I
haven't read it yet okay um have you
guys started thinking about
um who might direct this or is that
still early days
it surely takes
is there any chance Keanu that you could
direct it
um
there is
I I this is something that I've been
obviously uh you have directed before
um is it something that you
realistically like I like I like Ron's
reaction
um is it something that you like what do
you pers what do you put the percentage
chance that you might direct it at
33 percent
I think it might be higher but can you
sort of talk about what is it because
you've never I mean what are you is the
challenge of starring and directing in
something like this you know
um something that really excites you
does it make you nervous
um you know what I mean
what I I know and how it's a it's a lot
of it's a lot of um
work
and but I
you know the film that I directed Man of
Tai Chi was born I became the director
because I was part of the writing
process and I didn't want to hand it
over
I was like oh okay I have to direct this
just right there yet I'm Berserker I
have to read the script
but I also I'm interested in having a
collaborative collaborator and what they
could bring to it
Ron did you want to add something I saw
your face no uh
I'm just thinking man
okay get that percentage up man I mean I
think it's
it's all you you should be doing it
Clint Eastwood does it
you know I mean you can do it I think
you
have it's your thing I mean your thing
everything is there any other questions
got any more questions
I was gonna say I'm out of time so uh I
will be rapping here um I will just say
listen guys I'm really happy that
everything is going well and um you know
please let me know I can help on the
site
thanks man I hope you're enjoying it
awesome listen I I'm I'm TR I'm really
looking forward to as this uh ends and
goes into other mediums all right thanks
Steve